[Musique]
c'est interdit les portables sur la
plage
[Musique]
parce que ça fait chier tout le monde
moi que c'est vrai moi alors pourquoi
vous êtes en train de téléphoner je le
récupère et
sert portable
pour récupérer ou oui mais je l'éteins
écoutez je les touche d'orange dans ma
voiture parce que ça
commence à nous parce qu'on a dit les
portables on n'en veut pas voilà
non non on à dire on n'en veut pas mais
ce qu'ils enfoncent dans le sable alors
d'accord
voilà comme ça on l'entend plus
je lui ai téléphoné à la télé parce que
je travaille à la télé j'ai retéléphoné
pour leur dire comment comment ils
accueillent les touristes sabah si vous
le prenez comme ça voilà alors votre
portable voilà
voilà mais j'irai le chercher à la télé
c'est un vrai monsieur fortin lui je
peux pas travailler demain vous êtes je
veux dire à la télé tralalala moi aussi
je vais le dire à la télé
[ __ ] déjà un c'est pas [ __ ] mais nie
pas [ __ ] agents des forces de l'ordre
alors je rêve et je je je du coup je ne
le sais
non j'ai nommé ce que je me suis assez
veut rien dire je m'en veux de la
bastille sur
crash
je suis beaucoup moins
ça fait deux ça fait des interviews des
interférences sur le système de
navigation est donc comme et à marée
basse le voyez vous venez au
commissariat de suite alors tiens pas de
suite moi je finis marron tuéni à 19
heures
les gens qui sortent du casino à qui on
laisse en effet déclaré
attendez que le relou comme ça alors hop
voilà
[Musique]
vous avez le droit vous de partir je
vous ai dit de partir témoin la met
juste et notre force mamadou bah oui ça
vous dit j'ai déclaré volé maintenant
voilà vous allez déclaré noyer c'est
aussi important j'ai toutes mes cartes
commerciales qui sont des spas jetables
non c'est pas j'attends et
savait pas nager
[Musique]